welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition and you're now
locked into the channel where we break
down all the latest movies new game
releases TV shows and comic books
throughout this video we're going to be
discussing everything that you need to
know about the 2019 Korean film parasite
as well as its ending there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch the movie yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown a
parasite parasite centers around the
Kim's a family that live on the poverty
line barely getting by living in a bug
infested basement and forced to do all
kind of menial jobs in order to get
enough money to live day-to-day and its
core parasite is a tale of two families
well three which I'll get into later but
primarily it centers around an extremely
poor father mother son and daughter and
a very wealthy one made up of the same
archetypes the Kim's okay take the
father Chung sook his wife son ki-woo
who later becomes known as Kevin and
ki-jong the daughter one day kee Woo's
friend gives him a large rock that is
supposed to bring them luck and wealth
whilst doing it he also informs ki-woo
that he's leaving to study abroad and
one of his clients the hai requires
English tutoring ki-woo hasn't got any
qualifications in this as his friend
knows however he says that he knows
enough English to fake it and after
ki-woo falsifies documents with his
sister he gains employment with the
parks ki-woo who now goes as Kevin
really catches the eye of dahye and he
also massively impresses mrs. Park who
divulges that she is struggling to find
an art teacher for a sundar song who she
believes is a genius
the song has had a pretty messed-up
childhood due to the fact that when he
was younger he saw a ghost in the house
and this has scarred him for life Kevin
tells mrs. park that he knows of a
brilliant our tutor that he will inquire
about and along with his sister they
carry out the same scam the title
parasite comes from the fact that by the
mid point of the movie Kevin has managed
to get his entire family roles in the
home by each member recommending the
next one and they concoct devious ways
in order to get the workers at the parks
fired in order
for them to take their place the con is
on and the first hour of the film has a
real dark sense of humor to it as we
watch the group faking TB infections and
sex scandals in order to basically
develop a parasitic relationship with a
family in which the Kim's can live off
their wealth watching them manipulate
the pox is fascinating and early on the
movie will really get hooks into you and
I found it hilarious just how much doubt
they seated in the parks by simply
placing tomato ketchup on tissues and so
on it's a really unique and original
premise and it's no surprise that the
film is getting high praise across the
board I've never really seen a movie
that could be described as both a
thriller and a comedy and parasite is
extremely innovative whilst also
possessing characters that you can
really relate to Kevin gets too high to
fall in love with him and each family
member gains the trust's of the parks
which all leads to one fateful night
when they decide to go on a camping trip
they leave the property in the care of
Chun sook who along with the rest of the
family decides to spend the night
checking out how the other half live
however the households previous cleaner
arrives saying that she left something
in the basement and that she will only
be a moment while she goes to get it
moon Gwang the cleaner reveals that
there is actually a secret bunker under
the building that the parks don't know
about and that her husband has been
hiding down there for years operating
light switches and so on to make the
house seem like it runs automatically he
sends subtle messages such as Morse code
that subliminally let the occupiers know
that he is there and it keeps him happy
providing a safe place for him to live
as he hides from loan sharks who've been
after him all this time
it's where the film takes a real sharp
turn and I was open mouth throughout the
reveal of it I've heard a lot of horror
stories about people secretly living in
attics and so on for decades without the
occupiers knowing and watching it play
out and the film was brilliant moon
Gwang which year full disclosure have
probably pronounced everyone's name
wrong up until this point discovers that
the Kim's are also pulling a scam on the
parks and she attempts to blackmail Lam
saying that she won't tell the family as
long as they sneak her husband food and
don't tell a PAC's about him this blows
over into a big fight with the Kim's
managing to delete the footage of the
phone that moon Gwang takes as evidence
but just as they look like they're in
the clear the parks call and say that
they are coming home early due to a bad
store
in the area and this has bigger
repercussions later there's a mad dash
to clean up the house like when you were
a teenager and I had a house party and
your parents said they'd be home earlier
than you expected so you rushed around
clearing things yeah I'll never forget
that one bottle cap that left out that
got me caught anyway there's two sort of
sides to this with a mad scramble going
on behind the family's back whilst Chun
sook paints out that everything is fine
even going so far is to kick moon Gwang
down the stairs in order to get her out
of the way it's hilarious for all the
wrong reasons and during this scene mrs.
Park informs Chung sook about the songs
ghost who at this point we now know is
moon Gwang husband
the other three Kim's hide under a large
table in the living room and the parks
crash out on the sofa which is where mr.
Park reveals that Chi take has a smell
about him that makes him stink it's a
poor smell smells of rags smells worse
than this channel that just goes about
spoiling movies anyway they do a bit of
fondling and crash out and the Kim's are
able to escape however they're not out
of the woods yet
and the group get home to find their
basement flooded probably with that
guy's urine who keeps weighing next to
their house do they say wing in America
I don't know anyway back at the parks is
home moon Gwang dies from her concussion
right in front of her husband who Chi
take tied up everything at the Kim's is
destroyed completely washed by the rain
and it's kind of crazy watching them
going from this lavish fantasy life to
the depressing circumstances of reality
it's what makes parasites so endearing
and memorable and looking at the
desperate situation of the Kim's reminds
us that anything can go from great to
terrible in a matter of moments
Kevin picks up the rock that brought him
wealth and fortune in the home and they
have to sleep in a community shelter
surrounded by poor and desperate
families like them the picture often
portrays the poor as bug like crawling
around swarming with one another and
whilst that may carry negative
connotations it's very much the opposite
betraying the human side of just how
horrible living day-to-day can be it's a
sympathetic view that shows that
everyone is desperate to make money some
just happen to be more lucky than others
watching this song wake up and attend in
the garden juxtaposed with the Kim's
waking up in an overcrowded gym just
shows how big the divide of wealth is
within the world
and the subtext definitely makes you
feel sorry for the Kim's this is a
situation that's very much about keeping
up appearances though and the next day
mrs. Park throws a party for the song
and invites many people including the
Kim's
Kevin sneaks off and carries the rock
down to the basement intending to give
the good luck to others but Gwen se moon
Wong's husband grabs him round the
throat with a rope smashing his head
with the rock and then going to the
party he stabs Kees young and this
dramatic appearance triggers the song's
trauma and he has a seizure guy take
rushes to stop ki Jon's bleeding a mr.
Park shouts at him saying that he has to
drive the song to the hospital but he
doesn't move instead throwing the keys
of the car at him which are blocked by
Chun Suk who at the time is fighting
against a Chun Suk manages to kill him
but as mr. Park goes over to retrieve
the keys he is repulsed by the smell and
this reminds him of mr. parks comments
which have clearly been playing on his
mind
and he runs over and stabs him fleeing
from the situation after murdering him
it really goes from zero to a hundred
and this scene is one of the biggest lap
tunes that I've ever seen in a film it
really keeps you on your toes and no
it's pretty short-lived
it's very memorable and cements just how
unpredictable that parasite is both
ki-jong and mr. Park died from their
wounds and Kevin awakens in hospital
after receiving brain surgery he suffers
from damage and has developed a twitch
laughs uncontrollably and at the trial
with his mother the two are found guilty
of fraud AMPA on probation he take a
stayer large wanted for the murder of
mr. Park though the authorities have not
been able to locate him
they tail Kevin who still keeps a close
eye on the poxes house and one day
notice is one of the lights flickering
spelling out a message in Morse code
that he fled to the basement and has
been living down there this entire time
he buried moon Gwang and there have been
new occupiers that Chi take needs to
sneak around in order to survive
Kevin promises to become extremely rich
and earn enough money one day to buy the
house himself so that he can free his
father but this just seems to be a
fantasy and in reality Kevin is still
stuck in the basement from the star of
the film much like his father who too
remains in Warren paying the price for
the family's lies the film is very much
circular with the Kim's most notably
take once more relegated to living off
the wealth of others now will Kevin
eventually earn enough money to buy the
house though we don't know for definite
it is safe to assume from the director's
comments that he will not and that Kai
Tak will be trapped down there until the
end of his days when discussing the
film's ending the directors stated that
he had one of two options for how to
close it out the scene that we saw where
the family reunites or the one in the
basement showing the harsh reality of it
he chose the latter to hammer home that
the prior was just a fantasy dreamed up
by Kevin who has discarded the rock
possibly losing the luck that comes with
it if there is such a thing thus we can
draw from this that the downtrodden
ending of the film hammers home that
Kevin will forever be stuck in that
basement unable to escape the trappings
of poverty where the two will remain
barely getting by scrapping on food in
order to live one more day now you could
have easily cut when the two reunited
and this would have finished the film
with a happy ending however to have it
go on longer than it does definitely
cements to me that this is a tale of
reality wrapped in a fantasy and Kevin
will likely never complete his goals
due to his fraud conviction brain damage
and inability to move beyond the house
he will likely still obsess over it and
spend the majority of his time there
rather than working in order to build
his fortune and his father will be
trapped in the basement hiding from the
authorities it's kind of heartbreaking
and it's also what makes parasite so
special with Kai take you kinda wonder
would he not be better off in prison as
he's gonna be stuck in a cage either way
at least in jail though his family will
be able to visit him this is a very
off-the-wall movie that is both unique
in its premise and the way that the plot
plays out and it makes for a memorable
journey that is laced with sadness
throughout the reminds us of just how
good and bad that some people have it
parasite is incredible and it's easy to
see why it's being labeled by many as
the best film of the year there's very
little to fault here and with there
being so much in Hollywood that is
formulaic and repetitive this is a
breath of fresh air in terms of
storytelling parasite is a masterpiece
and it will likely be brought up in many
conversations for years to come with
people asking have you seen parasite
before going into just how good it is
and
have the person that they're speaking to
has to go and see it this is a brilliant
film and one of the best movies of the
air so far and that's why it gets a
perfect 10 out of 10 now obviously I
loved hear your thoughts on parasite and
what you took from the ending I've heard
a couple people say that it's very much
like Inception where it's completely
ambiguous so if you think the opposite
to me or agree with me then make sure
you leave your theory in the comments
below and if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and don't
forget to check out my full breakdown of
this weekend's big release a doctor's
sleep would you be linked at the end we
go over everything that you need to know
about the movie so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come chat to me after the
video then make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey will head
over to my discord server which should
be linked in the description below those
are the best ways to keep up to date
with all the latest videos on the
channel so hopefully I see you over
there very soon well so giving away a
free copy of the Marvel phase 3 part 1
boxer and blu-ray which contains Civil
War Doctor Strange homecoming Ragnarok
and more and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
parasite in the comments section below
the winners gonna be chosen on the 15th
and open when the set will be shipped
out from the end to ever gets the prize
it's the best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is the channel for
people who were mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]